a public school public elementary school
in florida
just took students on a field trip to a
gay bar
a gay boy this is rosie's
bar and grill it is a place for sassy
fun according to their marketing
materials
they took the kids there for a field
trip and showed them all the pride flags
and the rainbows and they were wearing
kind of little rainbow
t-shirts when they were there
and they had a presentation about
how great gay bars are i guess
this
uh
this
decision is shocking a lot of people
because they think oh my gosh how can
maybe the high school students but the
elementary school students how could you
take them to a gay bar
this is actually perfectly natural
i mean it's not
this kind of education would not be
natural but the broader premise that
you're going to
inculcate
your moral views in your students that
is
part of education education is in part
learning facts learning dates learning
battles learning math learning
arithmetic learning how to read and
write but part of education is teaching
people ethics morality how to live right
the point of public education is to make
people good citizens and now part of the
reigning ideology of the regime is the
rainbow stuff is the idea that any
sexual desire you have you should pursue
it is the idea that if you're a man who
thinks he's a woman then you really are
a woman i mean that's on our passports
now we'll get to that in one second
first though
i am so happy to tell you about get
upside this
app came just in time right now gas is
going through the roof
i am going to save you
at least 25 cents for every gallon of
gas that you
pour
every time you fill up just download the
free get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
knowles k w l e s get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up that
means up to 50 cents cash back per
gallon don't pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
down load the app for free use promo
code knowles know wles to get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred bucks a
month in cash back there's no catch your
cash gets right added into your bank
account cash out anytime to your bank
account to paypal to an e-gift card for
amazon or other brands download the free
get upside app use promo code
knowlescanwlis to get up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your first tank that
is code at knoll scanner wles you're
welcome so of course we're going to
teach elementary school kids this it's
only natural if they were in catholic
school well a lot of catholic schools
have gone pretty lit these days too but
if they were in catholic school
they'd they'd have mass they would pray
they would learn the sacraments they'd
learn about the saints and the ten
commandments
but they're not they're in lib school
they're in woke school and so they're
going to learn
the morality of of the left they're
going to learn the
anthropology of the left that's just
natural if you want to stop this kind of
thing it's not enough to just say hey
don't take kids to gay bars that's crazy
you you have to go a lot deeper than you
say hold on what are we teaching this is
what this is what the parents showing up
to their school boards is all about it's
not just about one or two crazy
incidents a a kid field trip to a gay
bar or even that horrible rape in
virginia it's not just about those
incidents it's about the whole thing
it's about the whole problem that
parents are being cut out of their kids
education that parents are not allowed
to teach the kids their moral views
their ethical views their their
civics right their the country that they
want to live in that's not being
permitted anymore and the school boards
are getting increasingly aggressive
about this i'm glad you like that clip i
like that clip too i want i want to see
you more often i miss you i want you to
see these clips more often the way to do
it is to ring that bell
subscribe
or if you sometimes youtube even when
you do subscribe doesn't send you the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch your google play
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review you will get
the new episodes uncensored unvarnished
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]